Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my Spider-Man freshman year video we got a bunch
more footage to break down a bunch more Easter
eggs we know more about the characters there's
also a bunch of other Spider-Man announcements
that have happened recently too if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we even just found out that Tom
Holland is officially coming back as Spider-Man
in Spider-Man 4. I've already done a video about
that so I'll link it in the description below
we're also going to be getting what if season
2 episodes at the beginning of next year too so
I'll address that during the video as well there's
a whole bunch of stuff to talk about because
we've got a whole bunch of new footage and a
bunch of details about Avengers five King Dynasty
Avenger six Secret Wars even Spider-Man across the
spiderverse I know there's a lot of questions
about the Multiverse and then bringing all this
stuff together because they are already crossing
over Tom Holland's live-action MCU Spider-Man with
Spider-Man across the spider verse and we did
just see Haley Atwell in live action as Captain
Carter like we saw during what if but the whole
idea with Spider-Man freshman year is they're
doing an animated series in the style of Steve
ditko's art like the animation all the characters
the universe is meant to look like Steve ditko's
comic books in the OG Spider-Man comics picture it
as being kind of like Spectacular Spider-Man
episodes mixed with the 90s Spider-Man the
Animated Series episodes and is going to start
with him being in freshman year with him getting
the spider bite and will follow him through
his origin story because it kind of skipped
over that during Captain America Civil War but
here's the thing because of some of the footage
they released some of the scenes like Norman
Osborne is a big character during Oscorp exists
Harry Osborne existing he has a relationship with
him and there are a bunch of characters in the
backstory for the character is very different
so it sounds like the show is going to be set
in a different universe and it won't be 616 MCU
Spider-Man like it'll be very similar but there'll
be a couple minor differences for example like
the look of the characters looks very different
looks much more comic book accurate but much less
like MCU versions of the characters for instance
Doctor Strange looks very different and in the
MCU when Daredevil is supposed to get his back
in black suit like the black Daredevil suit during
the new Daredevil episodes it'll look a little bit
different from this black suit and yes you heard
that right Charlie Cox is going to come back as
Daredevil during the series it'll be our genuine
Daredevil Spider-Man crossover in a way that you
didn't see during Spider-Man no way home like
that was a Spider-Man Daredevil crossover but it
was more like a Matt Murdoch Spider-Man crossover
or Matt Murdock and Peter Parker crossover this
time it'll be genuine Daredevil doing Daredevil
things being a vigilante with Spider-Man being in
this full Spider-Man costume although obviously
slightly different version of the Spider-Man
costume Charlie Cox said that this is actually
one of the reasons why he came back so they could
do crazy crossovers like this this is like the
beginning of Charlie Cox coming back as Daredevil
in a much bigger way like we saw some Easter eggs
because of the Kingpin character during Hawkeye he
just came back again during the She-Hulk episodes
we saw him in the Daredevil yellow costume which
was the original costume from the comics which is
why it's yellow they even made fun of it during
the series for being mustard in ketchup colored
he'll come back next during the echo series and
get another different costume maybe a version of
the red costume or the Daredevil Back in Black
costume and then during the Daredevil Born
Again series which they start filming really
soon they'll be 18 episodes episodes of that and
during that he'll get another new costume either
the Back in Black costume or the Daredevil bread
costume whichever one he didn't wear during Echo
but that's just the beginning I know you all have
questions about Norman Osborne and Green Goblin
because one of the villains will be Norman Osborne
who based on the footage in this universe seems
like he's running a version of Oscorp and has a
pre-existing relationship with Peter through Harry
Osborne like they did in the comics I believe he
and Harry are school friends like they were in the
comics and then he becomes sort of a surrogate
father to Peter and it's sort of like a comic
book backstory he cares about Peter and his son
but he's got all this Shady Oz Corp stuff going
on on the side Peter starts to think of him as a
father figure you see him at his house here this
version of Aunt May seems a little bit different
from Marissa Tomei but the funny thing here is
this looks exactly like the Captain America civil
war scene just with slightly different versions of
the characters like it's Norman Osborne coming
here instead of a version of Iron Man then
eventually he gets the spider bite we'll see that
happen get a version of that origin story he'll
make his first homemade suit and then as he's
having his first Adventure trying to learn to
save people use his abilities Norman Osborne will
learn about Spider-Man and try to sort of hijack
him like work with him slowly and then eventually
try to twist him to the dark side like he does in
the comics and in the movies as well join me or
die eventually they also said one of the suits
that he's going to wear during the series will be
the Osborne created Spider-Man suit like Norman
Osborne will create a new suit for this version
of Spider-Man I don't know how close it's going
to be to the comic book version but like this is
a comic book version of Peter Parker wearing a
Norman Osborne created Spider-Man suit you can
see all the goblin text sort of baked into it
they didn't say during the series whether or not
Norman Osborne has already become Green Goblin
but I think that we probably also see a version
that happened during the series and they also
did confirmed that they've renewed it for season
two and season 2 is called Spider-Man's sophomore
year he was a sophomore during the events of
Captain America Civil War but I'm assuming
that they would deal with more Green Goblin stuff
during season two like that would be a big season
one Cliffhanger then separately another group
of villain ones seems like they have a version
of the Sinister Six they just have not become the
Sinister Six yet but they all seem like very core
sinister six characters slowly coming together
over the course of the episodes there's a very
comic book accurate looking Doctor Octopus there's
a scorpion who looks kind of tech based There's a
comic book accurate chameleon the huge dude is
actually supposed to be a version of rhino when
he's not in the costume this really jacked looking
woman with a mohawk is a version of unicorn from
the comics this female villain with the black hair
the red streak in the blades might be a version of
tarantula because they said tarantula would be
one of the villains and we don't really know who
the third version of the character is supposed to
be but they got tied up with Nico minoru and Nico
is a character during the series so this could
just be a version of tarantula this scientist
in the lab coat is a version of Bentley Whitman
who winds up becoming the wizard character in the
comics the Firebase character here is actually
butane the one with the suit the fire can is on
his fist you'd actually see Spider-Man fighting
against him in a scene here in the house the dude
with the mechanical legs and the sunglasses is
supposed to be a version of Speed Demon some of
his allies that they showed off in the series will
be Charlie Cox's Daredevil like I said slightly
different back in black suit and he'll be the
Matt Murdoch lawyer by day as well they'll be
doctor strange who obviously looks a little bit
more comic book accurate to the original Steve
didco Doctor Strange Nico minoru from runaways
like I said there's even a scene of Spider-Man
and Doctor Strange both trying to save her from
some dark being or a Shadow Demon From Another
Dimension because she comes from a family of dark
Wizards so that's the Magic based connection to
Doctor Strange we also just saw a whole lot of
Spider-Man and Doctor Strange together during
Spider-Man no way home we'll see if they break
this universe during this series too also like I
mentioned they have a version of Harry Osborne
he isn't pictured in this lineup here but he
looked like the Steve ditko Harry Osborne that
you remember from the comics on the far left I
believe is meant to be pearl panagan who becomes
the wave character in the comics in the series
she's going to start out being Peter's Crush
at school and she's the captain of the women's
swim team because the wave character you get the
water metaphor the guy in the lab coat is actually
meant to be Amadeus Cho of all people so we'll
probably see some more Hulk Easter eggs through
his character and maybe some sort of connection
to the Bruce Banner Hulk we just got the She-Hulk
episodes we didn't see a version of Amadeus chode
during that but we did see some Easter eggs for
Red Hook like they did genuinely have a red Hulk
shout out in episode 8 and because of some of the
Easter eggs and black panther wakanda forever I
just did a first look video for Captain America 4
new world order for the Thunderbolt Ross version
of Red Hulk and what their plans are for Val in
the Thunderbolts but they are doing a version of
Red Hulk that's why they recast Harrison Ford as
Thunderbolt Ross inside the MCU Nico is standing
next to him like I mentioned on the far right we
actually found out that this young girl is Asha
she's just meant to be a genius from wakanda who's
attending their school at Midtown High she's sort
of like a young version of shuri in the series
they didn't say who the adult woman in green
next to her is supposed to be but the green is
just giving me Green Goblin Vibe so it could be a
version of Harry Osborne's mother and I think the
woman in yellow on the other side of them might be
a version of Gene Foucault finesse from the comics
the big football player is actually meant to be
a young version of Lonnie Lincoln who eventually
becomes Tombstone but in this version I believe
he's going to start out being Peter's friend
from school but there might be a Twist during the
series where he turns evil the slight variation
that they made to his first homemade Spider-Man
suit is just to have him wearing a hockey looking
Jersey with a custom Spider-Man symbol on the
chest in blue the colors are just like a little
bit different they're tuned up just a little bit
more and like his pants are just a little bit
different they did confirm there'd be like seven
different Spider-Man suits on the show including
the first homemade suit in the classic Steve
didco suit you see in the middle of the lineup
here but it's the red blue suit all five of these
suits include versions of the Spider-Man Slingers
team suit that's the big Easter egg here for those
of you that didn't read the Slinger storyline that
involved another team of people that Spider-Man
basically gave his suits to but from left to right
it's Hornet the black one is dusk the classic blue
and red Steve ditko suit like I said that was his
second suit technically the very first Spider-Man
suit was meant to be red and black which I talked
about during my Spider-Man far from home videos
because that inspired the version that he got
during that movie The White suit on the right
of that is either a future foundation suit which
kind of blows my mind because that also means
that the Fantastic Four were in this universe
and this last one on the right is Prodigy
it is meant to be a Kevin feige LED Marvel
Studios Production but I think it's going to be
treated in the way that they treat what if like
it is Canon to the Marvel Cinematic Multiverse
but it's taking place in an alternate universe
because like for instance during Spider-Man
no way home when we have the Tobey Maguire
Green Goblin come in and he goes looking to try
and find a version of Oscorp or find a version
of Harry Osborne he says that there is no ozcorp
that exists in the 616 MCU any implies that this
universe's version of Harry Osborne has already
died the big news with the series this past weeks
a lot of people wondered if it's potentially
canceled because there's a lot of talk about
Marvel animators being fired the series hasn't
been canceled they're still planning on releasing
it fall 2024 and they do have X-Men the Animated
Series they're doing a new season for that it's
basically season five of the show as if the show
never went off the air like a bit of a time Jump
that's why they're calling it X-Men 97 because
97 was the year that it stopped airing episode
episodes originally I will be doing full videos of
that when it airs because obviously we're going to
get a bunch of X-Men movies inside the MCU in
a live action once they start introducing more
of those core X-Men characters which is basically
happening in the next couple of years best example
of that is Ryan Reynolds Deadpool bringing Hugh
Jackman Wolverine into the MCU the series that
might actually wind up getting canceled though
are the ones in early development and just the
things that they're thinking about doing look
there are a couple unannounced projects that
Marvel's doing his animated series that they might
wind up canceling in the future the next big thing
is going to be the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special it's meant to be a prequel to Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 but after the events of Thor love
and thunder I'm allowed to post my review video
early next week so look out for that and then
I'll do like a full breakdown Easter eggs video
and talk about how it connects with Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 when it actually airs I just did a
bunch of black panther wakanda forever videos for
the post-credits scene full Easter eggs breakdown
I'll put links to that in the description below
everyone click here for my brand new Deadpool
3 video and click here for my Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special trailer video in Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!